every side of you for sure i think
that's important and
um
wait what let's another question guild
about six months ago about six months
into dating this girl that i'm currently
with she mentioned that she used to be a
stripper four to five years ago
and roughly for roughly a year and a
half this really shocked me and
ultimately made me uncomfortable
i do like her very much but every now
and then the thought of her stripping
does creep into my head and i try to
quickly bury it
i know this is my insecurities that are
making me uncomfortable about her past
but i'm afraid i will never be able to
get over it
am i an [ __ ] for judging her this
much about her past should i be able to
look past this
your fan jay yes uh as a guy that's
dated a lot of strippers
i'd like to say no i'm trying to have
you did you know either i dated
no i don't think i did no what do you
mean you don't think
no i think they were stripping or i
don't think they stripped
i don't remember i i i i've hooked up
with strippers i've never dated one yeah
yeah yeah but i think it's great that
you're already ahead of the game that
you're already
you know god you seem these guys they
both have problems and they already
seemed like
they resolved a lot already yeah but you
have to love the person for who they are
obviously you can't judge them
for anything in the past obviously and
whatever they went through made them who
they are at this
from when they met so it's obviously
made them
that person um but i you can't judge
someone for anything like that
you know for sure you know for me you
know in the last 10 years i've changed
my views on it
because on stripping no but like in
terms of like thinking like
because i know now that a couple of
female porn stars that are
very big in the game right that are in
relationships or they're married
right and and for me it's like i used to
think that like
oh i could never you know date or
marry a porn star or something right but
once you get to know these women that
you know that it's just an occupation
right right it's a it's also very like a
bank teller
yeah yeah yeah like a bank teller yeah
yeah and they
exactly chris and then they yeah it's
exactly
and that and that they um it's also
artistic it's almost
because like like we talked about assa
because asa akira has done our po
our our podcast three or four or five
times right
she's very creative when she you know
does her work
it's acting right it's it is yeah yeah
getting that semen
out of the out there yeah yeah yeah so
what i'm saying is is that
is that the case like he's weirded out
that she's a stripper well he answered
his own question he said he was
interested
here and that has nothing to do with her
it is all to do with you
yeah yeah whatever she did and you'll
find that in therapy too you'll find out
that
uh yeah that's that's such an
unfortunate a lot of projecting
oh yeah if it's it's really hard for him
the fact that other guys desire her
yeah no he's insecure about the fact
that she was once upon a time a stripper
which is
absolutely that's uh for me if i if a
guy ever
let's say if i had that profession five
years ago and he would throw that in my
face
that is the biggest red flag it's a game
changer imagine i know for a fact that
if i had told you that if i strip from
18 to 20 you wouldn't have given
two i would have blinked an eye exactly
like what does that have to do with it
how much does that make five cents what
do you mean me
you [ __ ] like what does he mean
yeah you can't have judgment no that is
like that's a wrong move buddy
do not and if you're gonna if your
judgment is gonna get in the way of
you know loving stuff just tell the
person you can't deal with it don't
waste their time
yeah exactly you know grow up grow up
don't make her miserable just because
you're insecure yeah positive insecurity
yeah love you though jay jay jay
love love you chris hey chris i love you
xxo chris
chris kathan are you falling asleep no
i'm just
i want to ask you um is there anything
that you want to promote
oh sure well uh i have a book called
baby don't hurt me
which is true okay and uh
i didn't think um what i didn't think
you were lying no i know i think
i know yeah uh what else to promote
instagram at chris katan